Now, let's turn to the implementation of the display method. It's supposed to
display a choice question in this format. First, the text of the question. Then
all of the choices, and we put a 1, 2, 3, 4 in front of each of the choices in
case the poor test taker is too frazzled to figure out the numbers themselves.
It's easy enough to do this part. All we have to do is loop through the choices
and print them with a number in front of them. And since this has nothing to do
with learning about inheritance, I'm just going to give you this code. It's
right here. So we print the number of the ith choice and the ith item. actually
not quite because in Java the choices have indexes, zero, one, two, and three.
And we chose the more traditional one, two, three, four, which accounts for the
i plus 1 over here. The hard part is to display the text of the question. And
again, the question text is in the Superclass object, and we can't get at it
directly. Let's have a look at the Super class. Here is the question text, do
we have any method that let's us read it? there is, And we could call display,
and then it would print it. That's just what we need. let's do it. Here I call
display that should display the text and then here I am displaying these
choices around the demo. Oh! something very bad happened, I got a
StackOverflowError. Now, that's technical link of for having a method that
keeps calling itself. why itself? See the method is called display and here it
calls itself. That's a problem, I didn't want to call my own method, I wanted
to call the display method of the Question class. So my difficulty is that I
have two methods called display in the Superclass and in the Subclass. And they
have the same name. That's exactly what always happens when you overwrite a
method. Now, there's a special syntax for invoking the Superclass method and it
looks like that. You simply say super.display. Go ahead and give that a try and
fix up the display method.